die pig we'll we'll talk
i've died piece of garbage no i jumped
to my death no i didn't oh now i jump to
my death
hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the new sony m9 monitor
we've got h9 wireless headphones and the
new h3 wired headphones these are all a
part of sony's new gaming brand called
enzone specifically catering towards
gaming accessories so first up
let's open up this monitor
oh boy
here it is can you still see me can you
see me no no you can't oh that's fine
this isn't about me
it's about
you so i'm very interested to see what
sony does with this new brand called
endzone
it's gonna be kind of it's kind of like
gaming focus so it's a whole new line of
accessories starting with this new
monitor and headphones look at you open
up welcome home
we've got
power adapter
cable
this looks like it's the base
oh my gosh it looks exactly like the
playstation
instructions
more
paperwork oh there it is there it is oh
boy
oh this is exciting
okay
check this out
i'm just excited that this has a speaker
in it because i've had some gaming
monitors in the past where they don't
have speakers i don't normally play
using those speakers but there are times
where i just kind of want to have
speakers on my monitor so it's kind of
crazy how that is something that
sometimes overlooked but this looks good
you look
good looks like we have three usb ports
here and another that you can connect to
your pc
we have a display port thunderbolt
another display port and two hdmi ports
and this is where our power is so here's
our power button and this little
joystick is how we control the menu
features let's take a little peeky peek
at our instructions
[Music]
that's attached
now
we go like that
look at wow this looks so good oh my
gosh i absolutely love it i love that
it's adjustable
love to see it
this is the sony m9 monitor it's a 27
inch 4k display with hdr
144hz refresh rate support for nvidia
g-sync and hdmi 2.1 the design is very
playstation 5 inspired with an
adjustable base it has customizable led
lights on the back and built-in speakers
it works on pc apple xbox and of course
if you're using it with a ps5 it has
some exclusive features so here's our
headphones there are actually three new
headphones that sony's releasing the h9
the h7 and the h3 and we have the h3 and
the h9 here to check out today but the
difference between the three is the h9
is 299 it has digital noise cancelling
32 hours of battery life soft leather
ear cups and it's wireless and bluetooth
compatible now the h7 is priced at 229
without noise cancellation which will
give you extra battery life so around 40
hours or so it is also wireless and
bluetooth capable now the h3s are only
99 and they are wired with a 3.5
millimeter headphone jack and there's a
wired usb a adapter for your pc gaming
needs now all three models do have
spatial audios so you're not going to be
losing any type of quality there so it
really depends do you want wireless do
you want wired and of course the price
as well so the decision is yours this
has the same mic muting and unmute as
the h9s and these are perfect for
plugging directly into your ps5 let's
open up the h9s first any excuse to use
a knife like i'm gonna use it like do i
need to cut this tiny little circle
sticker no
[Music]
all right we're greeted with a usb
c cable here they are oh look at this
here's our little usb wireless stick and
the headphones oh yeah oh they're so
light too
oh stickers oh my goodness i don't know
i got so excited about that but but i
did the h9 have a comfortable fit 360
spatial sound for gaming 32 hours of
battery life it also has this little
multi-use usb switch so you can switch
between pc and ps5 using this usb stick
for optimal performance these have
active noise cancellation an adjustable
volume wheel and these conveniently
placed buttons it will automatically
mute the microphone when the mic is
placed in the upward position and it
will unmute when it's down you can have
two bluetooth connections so you'll be
able to play your game and you can also
have another connection where you can
chat on discord or listen to music from
another source i really like that you
can adjust the listening experience
through the in-zone hub app it gives you
this little option so you can scan your
ears and you'll be able to get an
optimized sound tailored to your ear
shape
look at this
time to game hit me up that's it
game over
so the top of this is also very soft the
cups along the ears very squishy very
soft and it did kind of give a nice feel
like it didn't feel like it was hugging
my head too tight which i really like
because sometimes headphones especially
when you're gaming for a really long
time and you're wearing headphones you
do not want them to be squeezing your
brain because you will end up with a
headache and we've all been there so
here's the h3s i feel like these are
going to sell very well because they're
99 and they're wired i feel like this is
sometimes exactly what you need when you
want a game you just want a nice pair of
headphones that plug directly in and you
don't have to worry about anything else
charging nothing it's just ready to go
so i'm very excited to try these
[Music]
here it is look at these so they do look
very similar the first thing you'll
notice though is the microphone is
actually black so you'll be able to have
a little bit of a different look these
ear cups also aren't the leather
material they do seem like they're a
little more of a fabric-y feel
oh here's our
usb a 2 3.5 millimeter
headphone adapter definitely need this
stickers
yes all right
here they are check them out
the h3s so here's the 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack and like i showed you
earlier this is the little adapter you
can plug in so you can plug this
directly into your pc to use it through
usb let's put them on
see how the feel is
very comfortable feels very similar to
the other ones of course i have hair
that is kind of covering so i don't
really know if the leather or
the soft kind of little satiny feel is
different i mean
it feels very similar not gonna lie very
comfortable microphone
mute
unmute mute
unmute
the h3s have the same comfortable fit
360 spatial sound and they are about the
same size as the h9s there's no need to
recharge these since they are wired and
the adapter allows you to use both the
3.5 millimeter headphone jack and usb
type a devices for your pc this has the
same mic muting and unmute as the h9s
and these are perfect for plugging
directly into your ps5 now that we've
unboxed everything
time to go set it up
everything's all set up we've got our
playstation and we have our pc
underneath the desk so everything is all
connected and first we're going to start
with some pc gaming now this little
dongle here like i showed you guys
earlier has a little switch on it for
ps5 or pc so this is gonna connect to
our wireless h9 headphones so since i'm
using pc first we're gonna switch it to
pc and plug this in and we're gonna be
connected and now they are all connected
you can see that they're no longer
pulsating it's just glowing a nice
little color there
and
we're ready to get oh whoa they're
already on
okay hello hello can anyone hear me um
justine
has entered the chat i actually got a
chance to test this out in new york
before i got my hands on it here in my
studio they had them lined up and
comparing them to other different
monitors that are basically in line with
this one whatever monitor you happen to
be using at the time most of the time
they're going to look pretty great it's
when you start comparing them side by
side or you've gone from a lower end
model and then upgrading to say
something like the new m9 that's why you
really start seeing the differences the
thing that i noticed having this up
against some other monitors is how deep
the blacks are with the hdr this really
does bring out all of the colors and
highlights and it is incredibly
noticeable let's switch to our pc so i
can show you guys
the in zone hub where you can actually
go in and customize different things
like the led lights you can customize
the crosshair which i'm actually very
excited to try out when you're playing
first person shooter games so here it is
this is the endzone hub this is where
you can adjust all sorts of settings so
right now we're in the display settings
so you can do an auto picture mode so
you can turn that off or you can turn it
on here's some preset modes that you can
have all set gaming assist you can set
the response time to fast or faster in
the device settings this is where you
can adjust some of the volume settings
for your headphones or the speakers and
you can also personalize the leds so
when you scroll down here this will let
you pick which color you want to change
it to we're going to change it to
magenta please yep love it now that the
headphones are plugged in you can see
here they just popped up right in the
endzone hub and this will give you a
bunch of different options you can
adjust the volume game chat balance you
can turn the noise canceling on off and
you can even set up the spatial sound
personalization and that's where you
take a photo of your ears and it
automatically will adjust to your ear
shape which is pretty cool i think
everything is set up to my liking
uh let's play some games shall we can
you say something jake um
halo is not as fun as you think it is so
i can't hear you good
okay now say something uh halo's a great
game halo is a great game i heard you
hello
who wants to play the game yep that's me
look at me ig5 time
let's oh yeah hey noobs you're gonna get
pwned yeah i got oh god oh no no no no
no no i'm not ready i need every need to
reel i gotta reload oh god oh god
somebody talk to me here's the problem i
don't even know how to throw a grenade
on a pc somebody trying to shoot me
you're trying to shoot me you want to
play you want to go you want to go you
want to go are you seeping are you dead
you see b oh wow
the spatial audio though is incredible
hey pig
do you want to die
yep punched you right straight in the
face straight in the face
oh shoot all right looks great this
looks incredible i'm very into it but
first of all i need to know how to throw
a grenade
oh man the footsteps it's wild because
like
it feels like they are it feels like i'm
actually here
like i am i'm here i'm yelling so much
because
in my head i don't hear myself for not
touching a mouse and a keyboard in a
very long time i think i'm doing pretty
good and i will i'll pat myself on the
back
i'm here get away this is my perch come
here pig
show oh shoot show your face how's our
team doing okay i have the most skills
on my team if that says something
something's wrong i was your lead
leading killer and you didn't even
um anyway the graphics look incredible
the blacks are very deep and
the sound is amazing
so far i'm really impressed another
thing that i like is that i can adjust
this too so on the back there's a little
trigger toggle joystick whatever you
want to call it and when you push that
that brings up your menu system which is
great because this gives you full access
to
basically everything that you're gonna
need to do so you can just click over to
picture modes you can change your input
you have the usb hub you have all of the
options that you would have inside of
the endzone gaming hub on the computer
right here on the display but i actually
would like to test out
these these are the h3s which are
wired so i could just plug them in all
right let's try these ones on
oh yeah nice and adjustable they feel
very similar but i can already tell like
the noise cancellation like those ones
instantly have like a seal like they
just like suction to your head it
already blocks out the sound now i do
like this because i can just plug this
right into the playstation controller i
automatically have audio um hello who
wants to hop all the sticks anybody nope
okay mute so let's this is gonna be
actually a surprise to me
maybe a surprise to you i've actually
never played
this spider-man game and it has been
like the number one most talked about
thing since the playstation has been
released i've played it very briefly
doing some demos but i've never done the
entire playthrough so this is definitely
a crime that i have committed i realize
this but i think today it's going to be
the day i'm going to unplug this so that
you can hear the audio
and hear the speakers
i mean they sound pretty decent i mean
they're obviously not like the best
speakers in the world but the fact that
this does have that built in i'm very
excited about it
[Applause]
i really like this monitor it's almost
like the perfect size i feel like i've
sometimes made the mistake of thinking
that i need to have a larger monitor to
play games on and
i actually feel like this 27 inch is the
perfect size here we go i've hit some
trees
[Applause]
here we go we're going up we're going up
the one thing that i can obviously tell
is how incredible the colors look and
having a 144hz display everything is
smooth it's seamless and it looks
incredible i really love the interface i
really actually like the zone hub the
fact that it all just connects
automatically and i can make all of my
changes in there i love the customizable
led i love the fact that i can just
adjust this a lot of times monitors
don't let you adjust the height like
that so that is really really cool oh
gosh okay hold on a second web strike
great took care of business anyway this
is just a first look at oh gosh we're
fighting again
i'm not ready i need to tell my people
that we have to go well thank you guys
so much for watching this is the first
look at the new m9 monitor by sony and
it's really exciting to see this new
enzone brand and some of the first
products that are coming out under that
i'm looking forward to checking this out
and i feel like i have found my new
gaming monitor i'm so excited to
actually finish playing this game so
with that i will put links in the
description if you guys want to get
information about any of the stuff that
i talked about today and i will see you
in the next video peace
[Music]
tap r1 repeatedly okay
oh i'm sorry